[Music]
next about books
we begin with a literary breakfast
hosted by random house publishing
william f buckley composer stephen
sondheim and others consider the uses of
the english language
and later historian alan taylor
discusses his pulitzer prize-winning
book william cooper's town power and
persuasion on the frontier of the early
american republic his business records
and some quite fascinating records now a
discussion hosted by random house
publishing about the uses of the english
language
participants include author roy blunt
new york times columnist and former
executive editor abe rosenthal composer
stephen sondheim and william f buckley
this discussion was part of rant house's
literary breakfast series and was held
at fred's restaurant at barney's new
york
good morning
good good morning
good morning good morning good morning
i'm trying to get a word in edgeways
here
morning
what a fantastic turnout and
no wonder in
view of the panel i want to apologize to
people here mr gill and others that i
have my back to you enid this morning
because i have to face the c-span camera
on pain of death to introduce the guests
and instead of the usual
anarchy which prevails when i introduce
them today we have alphabetical order as
a kind of tribute to the subject of
today which is the word
and so i begin with roy blunt
you say it blunt where is he here he is
i've got to face this way roy sorry
which plunges us all in
into the soup straight away
um
he's the roy of all trades linguistic
expertise with the rest of the panel
he's a usage consultant of the american
heritage dictionary
but is the only one who has rafted the
amazon and been attacked by a piranha
fish
unless i'm surprised by my colleagues
william buckley behind me
founder of the national review
holder of the presidential medal of
freedom
has just published the right word which
we celebrate today
it's only his 37th book
he's the lexicographical snob
where is he
and
this is him
and very wait for this he's very
heuristic
adjective which will also use as a noun
and say that buckley is an heuristic
and if you don't know what that means
you come to the right breakfast
an olympian leap in the alphabet takes
us to a rosenthal columnist foreign
correspondent
pulitzer prize winner who ran the new
york times for more than 15 enlightened
years
he was the daily drill sergeant of a
chinese army of words
and why did he get them on parade on
time
as sapphire
poet
performance poet and novelist who was
taught reading and writing to teenagers
and adults in harlem
for eight years a novel push is really
poignant and funny it's a stunning
evocation of the voice of a black street
girl of
16. i'll give you a kind of i can't do
the words but let me just give people
the flavor
of the pros boys say i'm laughing ugly
he say clarice is so ugly she's laughing
ugly his friends say no that fat [ __ ]
is crying ugly laugh laugh
and it's an absolutely fantastically
funny and moving book and jesse
scheidler the gatekeeper
no word or usage gets into the random
house dictionary without a shy lower
good housekeeping stamp of approval
he is also may i unmask him this is the
author of the book the f word
he wouldn't think it
and finally
in the sweeney todd chair
his last chair here is stephen sondheim
the celebrated pulitzer prize winner
the assistant composer passion sunday in
the park with george west side story
and many other
brilliant achievements so let me begin
with the
renegade the the the lexicographical
snob
the man who invites more rage
for his use of the obscure
uh buckley you are
why why should you want to rescue a
survivor from some greek
linguistic shipwreck like heuristic
just defend yourself buckley well give
me a
mean the same synonym uh
nagging no sorry
come on give me you give me tell
everybody what it means in your life
heuristic
legal defense is one that takes
advantage of all the loopholes and is
very long drawn out
so i don't i don't know another word
that quite does that
but if you want to uh i received this
letter from ken galbraith yesterday
and this might help you out a little bit
he says uh
i take it from your letter that i should
close down on endorsements for a while i
had thought of giving you one for your
recent book
it would have been
everybody knows that william buckley is
a master of words it is only the use to
which he puts them that restrains one's
enthusiasm
but defend it let's get again
you really rejoice in using words that
nobody else understands no
yes no no no no no no well that's that's
like saying felonious monk uh rejoiced
in playing a 11th chord with a raised
ninth he just thought it was the right
chord to play at that moment in the
music
okama doing 87
it's not really a court
[Laughter]
uh roy do you how what do you think of
this undemocratic champion on your
well i was reading in mr buckley's book
about
his justification of using the word and
fracturous say that say that again and
fractious instead of ambiguous which
and on grounds partly of onomatopoeia
which i think is a welcome
acknowledgement
how you're not here
he uh
he justified using the word and
fracturous
partly on the basis of onomatopoeia that
it sounded more like ambiguous than
ambiguous itself did
and i think that's a welcome
acknowledgement of the
role of the ear in language i was struck
by how un
oral or oral
president clinton's speech was yesterday
there was nothing that really left out i
mean
there was one there was one a couple of
lines in the poem miller williams poem
which i i may not remember them quite
right but i do remember them um
i think i do
who has
seen learning struggle from teacher to
child
cannot
allow
ignorance to spread like rot which
has a nice ring to it i think at least
the word rot has a nice ring to it uh
and i think that that more and more uh
speakers today and writers neglect the
uh
the uh the ring and thump of words and
just sort of get awfully
abstract that's certainly not the truth
of the case of anybody sitting here
especially sapphire that's not what i've
been reading but uh
uh well most language is spoken rather
than written which brings me to steve
sondheim
how do you respond to that i mean do you
think the spoken word is more important
than the written word it's not a
question of importance it's just it's
fun
it's okay hello hello we're having
trouble here with the microphones with
the sound master
how's this
okay yeah i said uh
the the fun of the language it seems to
me uh is is the is the sound of it and
um
uh i know when i read i hear a voice
speaking the language and uh i it's very
interesting what roy says about words
like rot i think you know the the the
real the core of the language are the
all the anglo-saxon roots as opposed to
the the fancy words which are for
decoration for icing like and fractuous
and heuristic and that sort of thing
which i think that that's spice because
you you want you want dessert as well as
well as nobody's dessert yeah okay
but it's uh i i don't know if uh if bill
uses aristic inn uh when he's talking
when he do bill when you're talking
oh shoot i should talk that with my dogs
my god
that explains it hey
just how can we gonna come back to
language and sound just let me just stay
for a second if you don't mind on this
this use of the
the word that nobody else has heard of
and said
and sends them scurry into the
dictionary do you think it's a kind of
anti-democratic thing or is he saving
words that might disappear in this case
i
don't worry too much about democracy but
um i must say that although i am about
the
14th or 15th
most fervent admirer of mr buckley in
the american press sometimes goes up one
notch sometimes goes down four but
generally that's uh when it comes to
these uh lovely looking strains when it
comes to uh so-called
difficult or long or
unusual words
uh i feel something like uh
character played by audrey hepburn in
one of her movies
when
cary grant or
pecker whoever it was
went up to put the move on her
and she looked at him and said
i'm very sorry
i have so many friends now
that i have no room for more until
somebody dies
uh at my uh i now feel that i have a lot
of quite a i know quite a lot of words
already how many do you think you know
all together
in one way or another more than buckley
i'm full up with words and and like
mcgovern i'm more much more interested
in
in how they're used and
which he is an expert of course and are
much more interested in other aspects
many other aspects of writing
uh and even speaking and communicating
to word use a word i never either say or
write
then i am in acquiring
uh more words well the trouble is you
know that means you you would be a kind
of uh
rejecting new words all the time and
they must be discarding old ones that
quite no i don't reject new ones i
sometimes make them up
which i feel you know i use words as
verbs instead of nouns or vice versa and
i'm not i'm not against them i just say
that i have i'm
and i'm fairly seriously about this that
as a sometime writer uh i uh
i
it's not what attracts me either to
reading or writing and certainly not
uh in bill's books what attracts me to
bill's books or his brain brains rather
than the words he plays with
enjoys what do you feel sapphire about
these strange outlandish
about the words um
i don't i don't know i i think what i
think is going back to the thelonious
monk why would you know one person try
to confine another person's use of words
i mean they're not the words i use or
particularly need but that's like saying
um aretha franklin should only sing in
the range i can sing people use the
extent of language that they need for
themselves and that hopefully you know
there'll be other people who can use it
and too it's not the language um i need
but then it's it's the language somebody
needs but most of us can
listen to aretha franklin and get it
but if the people you were teaching in
harlem had to read something by bill
buckley
they wouldn't get it well that would be
something to to strive for again i mean
you don't want to
create this little one-inch um
strata you know where people don't
strive to use other kinds of language
we're going to come back to ebola and
all that okay
jesse
bill buckley is not writing for people
in harlem you know his audience is
is very different from that and i was
reading recently robert birchfield who's
the former editor-in-chief of the oxford
english dictionary uh noting that he was
asked why is it that anita brookner uses
these words like rebarbative and
nugatory uses these hard words
and his answer was well maybe she
doesn't think they're hard
which is a great response and uh yeah
and i personally i like the fact that
you use words like and fracturosity and
all that i never see them you know the
uh the right to enjoy a property that uh
someone else thank you based on usage
i was
i was i was keeping
[Music]
yesterday i think it's in the sunny
times a new word which was new to me at
any rate it's not in the random house
dictionary it was a feminist letter to
the editor complaining that the reviewer
of a new translation of the odyssey had
not remarked upon how
lingo romantic the odyssey was
and i was fascinated by word because at
first i thought it had something to do
with the love affair with the language
or something and then i thought it might
even have to do with french kissing
but
then it occurred to me that lingo
probably came from lingam which is
sanskrit for the male organ which i
assume is true
so i i don't know whether we'll be
seeing link lingam romance lingo romance
around but i want to be the first person
to bring it up at breakfast
i also also have a better term a shorter
term for it would be for lingo romance
would be phallic froth phallic froth
okay
sounds very close to something else um
stephen the sound there's another
example of the sound when you're
composing a lyric
do you stride about the room uttering
the sounds rather than looking at the
printed page um
it depends uh it depends on the
character the the whole thing is to get
get the words that that character would
use as opposed to the words i would like
to use uh it's a lot of fun to play
around with with fancy words but most
characters and most most of the shows
i've written wouldn't use that kind of
language so generally i don't i don't
speak the lyrics i sing them because
there's no lyrics don't exist without
music and when your works are translated
what happens to the careful i don't know
enough about foreign languages but i
know that a lot of my stuff is not
translated because it's very verbal the
shows that get translated are ones that
are less verbal
and because playfulness with language is
something i i enjoy a lot in the in song
and um
so i i don't i don't know enough about
them i i rely on on other people to tell
me what the translations are any good or
not if the if the thrust of the song
isn't most of us
are obviously obsessed by words not in
the beginning your presence
so much in the scholarly senses in the
impact they've made well one of the
things about translation is
for music is you know the music of any
country is reflective of the language
sorry the music of any country is
reflective of the language and uh you
know the reason for german music
sounding the way it does is because the
german language sounds the way it does i
think translation is at most of at least
a very hazardous thing indeed
particularly when it comes to setting it
to music are you against the the uh
rendering into english of uh italian and
german well i i don't know enough
foreign language so uh the only
only times i can enjoy operas when i
don't understand what they're singing
i have a mark twain which i must unleash
when he mentioned german
uh mark twain wrote a sentence he which
was marvelous he says whenever the
literary german
starts to speak he dives in you lose
sight of him he dives into the atlantic
and at the other side
with the verb in his mouth emerges
uh which you know the german with the
verb at the end talk about the impact of
words i mean we're talking about this in
a kind of
cool scholarly way
and it's interesting but really the
point about words is that a single word
like [ __ ] [ __ ] jew limey [ __ ]
can have a tremendous impact and cause
tremendous offence
should we ban some of these words
uh i
it's not a question first of all it's
not a question of banning them uh i just
don't think they should be used unless
they there is no other way possibly if
the president of the united states gets
up on television or something and uses
one of these words i don't think they
should be banned we should report them
uh but you wouldn't report those words
and you well we once reported an
obscenity in the new york times
uh the only time that i'm conscious that
we don't use them
uh
for a lot of reasons one was the
trademark as soon as we start using them
just like everybody else um
but once we did uh that was during one
of the nixon tapes
where the
expletive was not
eliminated and of course all the
reporters were sitting around
waiting to see if i we would use this
word
eagerly watching me
watching if i would crumble uh but uh
since it was in the text we
made a use this i made a decision to use
i wasn't going to censor the president
and the word was uh
[ __ ] what it was [ __ ] at times that word
was [ __ ] i'm sorry
and uh but i got something out of it
because i was ready
with an answer when magazines would call
and say
how come the times
did this it's the first time
and i had my answer ready the new york
times will take [ __ ] from the president
united states but not from anybody else
i kept repeating that until finally
somebody printed it
but i want to say that quickly
my professional interest and my personal
interest is much more not so much in the
use of words the damaging the abuse of
words abused by words not of words but
not so much in the ones of racial
epithets and the things that people
normally avoid
but the things that seem quite innocent
but are not and result in a total
distortion of the either the person's
character of or the situation
uh he or she is i'll give you a couple
of examples
uh and as
as the editor of the times for all these
years
this was one of my
things i watched as carefully we all as
we could king charles's head is the
phrase you're struggling for all right
now let me tell you uh the um
uh
police found a
shortage in
in the accounts of uh
ex-company uh but the uh uh chief
accountant
uh mr so-and-so claimed he knew nothing
about it the man is dead on the spot
yeah
there are others there are claim it
implies guilt right or uh absolutely but
it's used all the time there are others
that uh
the punctuation can be deadly
just plain punctuation i always watched
out and i think the time still does
before i used to call the cowardly
commas
if you see somebody's name
with a comma after it
watch out
[Laughter]
uh example uh and there's a comma
phrase
or clause another comma
uh i'll make one up uh
claudia clancy
comma
daughter of the publisher who was earned
uh
putnam
i guess is putnam
50 million dollars
comma
yeah
today received
an unusually large advance for her as
yet unfinished first novel yeah period
yes now every word and that is true but
it's all a lie the commas make it a lie
exactly right so you uh this is the
abusive words the use of and sometimes
it can lead to terrible tragedy and i'm
saying all this because i believe
that my friend uh or our friend jersey
kaczynski
uh
was
hastened
toward his death
by being denounced as a
plagiarist
i saw him
uh we all saw him
not crumble because he kept his but we
saw his him devote the rest of his life
to trying to prove he was not uh
plagiarist and it ate away at his spirit
it weighed ate away his creative
energies and his he would say hey when i
go out to minneapolis to make a speech
i'm no longer jersey kaczynski who has
written 10 novels
i am that fellow
isn't he a plagiarist
and that's what he was fighting it's the
temptation to put an adjective in front
of everybody's noun
bill
since we did mention the protocols of
the new york times
uh i had a lot of published in the times
day before yesterday and in the original
i quoted a particular paragraph
and then i said that's a hell of a
paragraph and then went on to analyze it
so they said could they put heck instead
of hell
i said no put in inferno
which i did
i would like that let's see
stephen's going to ask a question i want
to ask a question because a lot of
publishers here and and
what what what is
why are our
so-called obscenities uh not used
they're used in some publications some
you know uh uh
very popular publications and
why is there such a a ban on them in
let's say a newspaper what is the reason
for that that you would lose so many
readers if you if you published a
four-letter word have you tried to
smuggle an obscenity into the atlantic
or somewhere
i've tried to submit any publications
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not in mr rosenthal's rugged time
it's true
jim bowden said i forgot who he's
talking about somebody who was invited
to the yankee old timers game and he
wasn't he said i don't know who it was
uh phil lynn's or something he said phil
lens couldn't carry my jock strap and uh
came out in the times phil they called
me and asked me about it i'll tell you
that i said well was this in residence
the whole time you see i told you
um
jesse what's your attitude to that when
you come to compile addiction and the
man who wrote the f word do you believe
that
since you put the word into circulation
do you believe that
steve's right that there's a kind of
petty puritanism prevailing how's that
for alliteration
well there are a few different things to
consider as far as dictionaries go
dictionaries don't recommend words or
anything like that dictionaries record
the words that are used in the language
you're a kind of pusher though really
sorry you're a kind of pusher
i mean you put them into circulation
well no because the the f word for
instance has been around for about 500
years but it's only been in the last 30
that it's made it into dictionaries so
you can't say that dictionaries are the
cause of people using the f word or
anything like that
and words like that that are very common
and there's a reason that they need to
be in the dictionaries because they are
common at the very least if they are
words that are offensive or vulgar uh
you have a responsibility to put them in
just so you can note that these are
vulgar you go around looking for things
like this
i mean are you going around looking for
things like this all the time actively
actively
and if anybody want to say anything
really rude this morning
please say to my guest jesse
privately
an old reporter there said he was he
covered world war ii
and uh he was on a battleship that was
strafed by japanese airplanes and
the uh
and he there was an american sailor
standing on the deck shaking his fist at
the planes going over and saying uh you
[ __ ] japs and he knew the paper
wouldn't print can we can we take that
huh can we continue okay let's go we're
going to edit this tape i thought
but the
oh i'm sorry
but the uh but anyway the reporter um
knew they wouldn't print that so he
changed it to you damn japs and then the
copy desk changed it to you darn [ __ ]
now of course it has to be you darn
nippiness oh gosh and golly and gee whiz
what is the philosophy behind that
so-called family newspaper what kind of
family doesn't know what's that what
kind of family doesn't know those words
family news
uh i would agree with you that's
puritanism but i would say that's petty
uh puritanism itself is not uh a uh
necessarily an evil thing
uh if it's uh something you wish to do
or or adopt because you do not wish to
do something and it's not forced upon
you
the reason this is our times ours the
people who run it and the people write
for it and so on we have we have a
feeling about it and our readers a paper
is a
uh doesn't exist by itself it's a
catalytic reaction among the staff it
it's it's and it's it's publisher it's
purpose it's audience
uh and
we
we it's we have felt for and we still do
i'm not sure i get all worked up about
heck
or darn or something uh in fact i
wouldn't and i certainly it's
hypocritical only in the sense that i
use these words in my
life rather too much
but my life is not necessarily the life
of the paper with which we have been
entrusted which is not a
dirty word either
and uh we have a personality the
personality of that paper has moved over
over time
could somebody stop the guys above
get in there too beneath him
that's somebody
right
the personality of the paper has moved
on very important things the kind of
news we cover there were no taboos
anymore
but but
on the question of uh obscenities uh
there was a feeling among all of us i
think which may change with another
generation but right now it hasn't that
the use of obscenities would signify a
change in our
vision of the paper and the love for
respect for it the and for the readers
that we don't want to convey let me ask
you a question
yeah well never mind never mind a little
bit i didn't ask you report somebody how
you said something when you're in a case
where there's a riot in the street and
the cop has said something or somebody
else has said something which is really
provocative and you don't report the
language because it's obscene
you can't say he made an obscene remark
and what he said
well if if the street language or even
the language of cops
uh were our only were our criterion uh
we would have the paper full of it
and uh if if if you're writing fiction
you you can control it but if you're if
you're you decide that you are going to
report totally the language of the
streets then your the paper would of
necessity have to be followed we prefer
it
but how amount of preference i know okay
the audience can come in on this but how
would how can you actually do justice to
the context in which the crime took
place in which the riot took place
unless you know the words which somebody
said i mean i have shared the same
problem with you as a newspaper i think
that over a period of time the new york
times and other newspapers have have
done a pretty fair job of uh
of alerting the readers to their
crimes in the street and the horrors of
this straight into poverty and so on far
more than any other institution
here's a guy who's in an angry situation
okay he says what the hell he likes and
you're going to come and clean up his
language he sounds right yes because
they're in everything there is a
trade-off in this and we think we would
have we we prefer the kind of paper that
trades off
the obscenities let me kill the sapphire
first thing
you want to follow on immediately go on
or does not shock exclusively
as a question of the context in which it
is uh used
when norman mailer's first book was
published
the um pacific book what was it called
the word
the f word was f-u-g-g
all the way through
and
john wrote in a review in the new leader
pointed out that
uh the
the f-word we're talking about is used
so
habitually
in barracks talk has to be invisible
yeah but the minute you spell it fugg
every time you see it it hits you
and therefore it distorts the reality
that the author attempted
now you can't
you can't expect a word that is used
as habitually as that word is to appear
in the new york times
uh with without giving it a prominence
that
that affects
uh the integrity of the original usage
are you convinced
well no first of all it's a lot more
reporting than good than just street
riots i mean why again what about letter
writers who who use a word
for this for the flavor of it then when
they say hell they mean hell they do not
mean heck it has a different tone and
then it is it's not censored uh i don't
want it
since ronald reagan
well except in the new york times look
sapphire your book is full of wonderful
street language did you have any
problems wrestling with your conscience
about it
well i i was trying to accurately um
report in a way what i had what i'd
heard
young people use so i felt very
comfortable using the language and i
felt that um
readers
would have a choice of
you know picking up the book and opening
it and deciding whether or not they want
to buy it in a way that they might not
have with them the
you know the headlines of a newspaper or
something so i didn't i didn't have any
qualms about the language i would your
book wouldn't have been your book
without all those
that language no i wouldn't um have um
allowed it to be published without the
language that i used did you have any
problem with your publishers
um speak freely no
um
not not not with the actual usage of the
language sweet knot sounds like a yes to
me
um yeah i i think um
some of the content was more problematic
than the actual use of the f word and
the p word and the d word and the s word
you know that type of thing anybody
wants addiction to those see this man
okay
so um
bill
you said his phone was that a question
yeah no it was a question i wanted if
you wanted to come back on that because
you were saying that
you wouldn't apply it to the novel would
you the the sensitivity of yours
well you did with the the the novelist
is attempting two things
one he wants to transcribe reality
i i.e to
suggest to the reader how in fact these
soldiers talk to each other or these
street people or whatever
but he also has to invest it with enough
artistry
to make it other than so conventional as
to be
boring
and
it's the combination of those talents
isn't it that uh
you know the first time uh
a four-letter word was used on the stage
in commercial uh
stage anyway it was as recently as the
mid-50s it was in captain hot tin roof
and it was when bur alive said [ __ ]
and it was that was shot heard around
the world nobody ever said a four-letter
word stronger than damn on the stage
before that
and now of course there's nothing but
you can find out what that means in your
dictionary right yes now just listen
to shock and let's come back to sapphire
and to others too for that matter
um
a phony new word has entered the
language uh when americans if i may say
so as somebody from other shores have a
tendency to invent these phony words
uh ebony plus phonics equals ebonics
hmm
well yeah that i i i think that is um
[Music]
um
a kind of a phony word for uh black
english or dialect um and i don't um i
haven't
it seemed to
just erupt erupted on the scene the past
couple of months so i really haven't had
a chance to
read a lot about eubonics or eubionics
so
what i can talk about is black english
or the
or english as it's used by
um people in the inner city your book
struck me as more dialect than the more
dialect than the
than the invention of a new language
your book is in english
exactly so uh in in the book the the
main character speaks in the language i
write in the language that the character
speaks in i'm not trying to create a new
language i'm trying to um to bring
to bring to mainstream america a
language that is already being used so
it's not a it's not a new language it's
an old language evolved from the south
from um
you know up north uh now
uh influenced by um
rap and um video and television in the
way that older black english was
influenced by uh you know church and um
uh certain kinds of oral traditions so i
find it completely comprehensible yeah
it's totally understandable if you uh
it's just
yes maybe when it's spoken it's harder
to understand but when you write it down
like father and laugh you know and all
exactly what you have is
very vivid mm-hmm
yeah
what you were just reading the little
excerpt you read it it it screams to be
heard
and but let's talk about the word
ebonics i i don't know if every
anybody feels that's a graceful word i
just think it's one of the most
graceless words i've i've ever come
across it
by the way
it's not a new word at all oh really the
early 1970s here we go
and it's a combination of ebony and
phonics right yeah and do you know who
who's responsible for this um
i can't remember his name but but a
linguist uh coined it around then you
know for this uh bill governor wallace
[Laughter]
i mean
i think that
too much attention can be focused on the
word harmonics and uh there there is a
point i think the whole ebonics uh
argument which is that uh what's called
black english
uh deserves respect and has internal uh
rules and uh it is a way of a form of
speech unto itself and it would surely
behoove
teachers of
black
people who t people who speak anybody
who's trying to teach somebody who
speaks that language should understand
that
language themselves i agree with that i
think that any teacher is going to be
you know the real
you know is going to have problems they
can't speak the language that the
students speak so if your kids are
coming anytime i i be coming and you
don't understand what they're saying
you're gonna you're at you're you're not
gonna be able to communicate with them
while your job may be to um
open the doors to them to the language
of power so for me as a teacher no
matter what language my students speak
whether it's black english or spanish or
russian i want them to the language of
power in the united states is standard
english and and that's what we need to
have
very important but i can't give that
language to them if i can't communicate
with them so it's very it was very
important to me teaching in harlem to be
able to speak the language that
the students in harlem spoke which was
different than the language i spoke in
texas it was different than the black
english i spoke in los angeles in san
francisco so harlem had a new language
we said mama they said mother you know i
had to learn that and uh i was going to
be at it
well it was it was about me
understanding them so i needed to know
when they said mother they were talking
about their female parent
so it wasn't so much that they were
having problems understanding me i
needed to understand their language so
we could hurry up and get on with the
business of getting the skills they
needed to survive
about
this umbrella term ebonics is there as
many varieties of black english as there
are of regional white english or exactly
or or spanish or anything else i'd like
to how do you open open your students up
to new words how do you is it through
through reading assignments or do you
pick i think the thing that people
forget is unless people are just
handcuffed most students are already
open you know they come wanting to to
learn new words they come
wanting to understand the world in some
ways that they feel locked out of so i
didn't i didn't have a a big problem
trying to introduce different kinds of
literature or different kinds of words
there were certainly sometimes that
people don't have the ability to to read
well and to um to to understand the
printed word then you have problems but
it the students minds are not closed the
students are trying to get out of the
hell they're in when they want
information
when they write for you do you encourage
them to write as you wrote and render
their speech in print or do you change
f-a-v-v-e-r into f-a-t-h-e-r
um
as as soon as i can with without
you know as soon as i can sense that i
can impart some information without
damaging
people or hurting them i let them know
that we we speak a different language
than the then is spoken downtown that
there is there are two ways of talking
that we say you know a father or a mama
and that uh the the other way of saying
it not necessarily the correct way the
other way of saying it is father and and
that what i want them to have is the
same choice i have so when i'm was
talking to my mother i didn't say hello
mother i said what's happening mama you
know what i mean but i had a choice i
could i could use both languages so what
i would want for my students is to be
able to switch back and forth to have
the uh the black english that is um so
beautiful and that is so creative and
that we that is our language and also to
be able to use the language of
of standard english the language how do
you relate it to the spelling if they do
when they will they sp do you ask them
to spell what they hear do you ask them
to spell it phonically i i think um
it depends on when you enter into a
student's life i think that
spelling by phonics is okay if you're if
you're dealing with someone who's
learning to read late in life but why
not just start from the beginning to um
with in in kindergarten and first grade
with teaching standard english and also
teaching how you can also spell
phonetically you know okay do you want
to spell my mother is coming or do you
want to say my mama be coming there's we
can write that either way and we can
learn to we can read zora neale hurston
we can read langston hughes we can see
how to reproduce the language that we
speak on paper authentically and we can
also see how to write the letter to the
publisher in standard english so we can
get our authentic language published you
know how did you react to this because
as a one of the custodians here
the the sovereign responsibility of a
dictionary is to attempt to maintain
standards there is no law save usage
if if the whole world decides to use a
particular word in a particular way
that's the meaning it will acquire but
not in today's dictionary in tomorrow's
and dwight mcdonald's wonderful essay in
the new yorker on webster three
he made that point and i did an
addiction in the
introduction i did to american heritage
dictionary that
there should be a wall of resistance
to uh innovations that are not really
thought through and don't earn their way
into uh into common uh uh addiction
so i don't think that um one should be
completely plebiscitary about standards
day after tomorrow yeah they have to
have time in waiting
now now webster did that would be they
would say uh um
what was the way they used um
unauthorized or whatever it was but they
they lift they lifted that
in 1953
uh
judging themselves to be
without any responsibility for usage
yeah but you are you're continually
going around rescuing obscure words from
obscurity
and you want therefore to welcome
this infusion of different dialects
different spellings different
yeah the 50 000 new words as i remember
in the last uh oxford i have no
objection to that but i i think this
that every time one wants to throw away
a word like san francis
uh they are throwing away a word which
once there was such felt need for that
it came into existence
now when uh when monsignor knox wrote
the introduction to the bible
uh
and had spent a lot of time
re-translating the bible and spent so
much time on the king james he said that
the king james scholars
had subsumed
13 different words into the single word
righteous
and as in doing so had set back ethical
uh
ethical philosophical explorations by
two thousand years
and those these gradations exist because
somebody feels a need to express their
nation if you simply say well
pull them all together into a single
word
you you sacrifice
all of that intellectual labor how do
you cope when you come to the dictionary
john updike in his essay on fowler's new
book was complaining
uh it's the only complaint he had as far
as i could see about usage was that i
couldn't care less has now been renders
i could care less which means the exact
opposite and yet it's used to mean
something quite different from what the
words say how do you cope with that
i
i could care less i mean no it's
sarcastic yeah it's emphasis on the good
let's try it then okay i couldn't care
less about your dictionary okay you
could i could care less i mean it's a
sarcastic expression
so it depends on a sundial of inflection
right so it's no longer is passed out or
written it's now a sound word
it is and this is also this is you know
a very sort of informal expression uh
it's not one
uh you know this is one that sarcasm
perfectly explains uh and it's been
around for quite a while and at the very
least uh dictionaries the dictionary
that do include these expressions have
usage notes about that
uh and
you know it's certainly a relevant thing
to say these words should mean if you
take them literally uh i couldn't care
less is the proper expression
but uh i could care less it's so common
that dictionaries have a responsibility
to include it that's it and it's the
same with usage books
that i could care less no it's not it's
a question of emphasis it's the sound of
the word i could care
oh god somebody could care more come on
that's that's emphatic
isn't it it's the sound am i not right
stephen is this is
element of prescription in them i like
the random house dictionary because it
has these little usage notes which i was
arguing with two highly literate people
the other night about
uh
whether
you could use bi-monthly to mean twice a
month i said that's wrong you can't say
that and they were saying you can't say
that and i said why can't i say it's
wrong they said you can't say it's wrong
because then they looked up a random
vow's dictionary and the second
definition of bimonthly was semi
semi-monthly and so there you have a
descriptive dictionary telling me i
can't say it's wrong i mean that seems
to me just as prescriptive as anything
else i think that some things like i
mean whereas uh
you know if you had a little note saying
uh uh people often use semi-monthly to
mean by by or by monthly to mean
semi-monthly but
i mean there's a clear rule there
there's not just a matter of uh
i mean there's a reason to hold on to
those words but the language is con
words are continually being misused
what's your favorite
disinterested is my favorite when the
people mean
impartial but they're using it for being
bored you know
what i'll tell you why that's being
frequently used i happen to have an
example good
um
absolutely it seems to me as things get
more and more relative people use toss
the word absolutely around a lot and the
other day in uh
there was a
an age of representative gingrich was
asked this question and the testimony
for the house ethics committee did mr
gingrich ever ask you to provide us any
information that was less than complete
or that was misleading
and the aids answer was absolutely not
although i have to hesitate to use the
word absolutely
the absolutely of britain is the word
brilliant i'll see you for lunch on
thursday brilliant that's right uh are
you coming to visit brilliant yeah well
i have i've had several events that came
to united the united states with the
word quite in england it means kind of
lukewarm
and i say how did you like my book here
and they say quite well in terms of
enthusiasm in the united states in the
term of depreciation in england in fact
of course america has given us some of
the best words in the english language
i mean can you think of english words
which would compare i think england has
given us some of the best words in the
american language no no can i just say
this we haven't given it to you we've
lent it to you
i got a problem with the literally
yeah yeah
i called you literally 15 times right
means you didn't call 15 times no
metaphorically not even metaphorically
decimate protagonist is a good one
people use people you're wrong on that
am i i'm not wrong how can i think they
could be important
there can be two protagonists two
leading characters yeah but they're not
antagonists necessarily romeo and juliet
were protagonists both of them yes
theoretically you can only have one but
in fact that's not true yes but it's not
doesn't mean an antagonist
who said it did
a lot of people say theoretically
whose theory is this and that
that's the trouble with the the the the
greek tragedy a lot of people instruct
you that indeed you can that you should
you should um jettison the superstition
that you can't
yeah
you got more than two protagonists in
the other no no i just think what
teacher is there the um and then the
dictionary should be
should be a little more prescriptive
than it is because otherwise words are
changing their meaning will lose in
enfielding the language
that many of these examples aren't
necessarily examples of words changing
their meaning in many cases words have
had several different meanings
uh for instance with disinterested and
uninterested there was never originally
there was not a sense that uninterested
meant i mean the traditional usage
distinction here is that uninterested
means not interested and disinterested
means impartial so a disinterested
observer
someone without any bias but he's not
necessarily uninterested
but originally these words did not have
this distinction you know this was
introduced later into the language
uh and then it became
19th century
if not later i don't know but uh
you know after that it was taken as a
gospel that these words were inter were
not interchangeable they had
separate meanings and they shouldn't be
confused but with almost any example of
words that have undergone some kind of
usage debate
you can either find many examples of the
so-called wrong usage in any great
author you want
or you know the meanings that are
supposed to be connected to these words
uh are not historically true or not
etymologically true
and you know while it's true that there
are various words that uh you know are
you know misused you know how you define
misused is a very difficult thing
because uh
you know words have been used in many
different ways over the years and and
the fact that some of them have
meanings that we uh establish is true
um
you know that that just changes it's
really difficult but it's worth the
effort that's the point
it's worth the effort isn't it
take too many meanings they can't be
used anymore they're not they become
useless and also
they become litigious almost you know in
the sense they're going to cause a lot
of trouble somewhere
battles after that heuristic battles
word id test new early test boasts or
almost most and you're proactive in your
proactive has been in the dictionary for
a number of years
i didn't know that what does it mean uh
anticipatory
um being done in advance of something a
proactive response why didn't they say
anticipatory
that's a good one just i tell you what
let's buy it
let's spend five minutes on that because
it takes me into gender
uh how is the panel divided on you know
man's inhumanity to man a person's
inhumanity person mankind womankind
chairperson how do you stand on that
um
gender
how i feel and is that it's it's worth
the effort i guess what um
bothers me more uh what bothers me a lot
is when i open a book and then there'll
be a disclaimer the author will say um
you know i really
you know we're we're fighting to
eradicate sexism and part of that fight
is the uh elimination of sexist language
but it's just so difficult to write him
and her so i will be using him
throughout this book but you know when
you see him i mean her
and um
and i think that's i i think that's um
just
a cop out and and lazy and and just
so you prefer again returning uh um
power to to where it always was instead
of a redistribution uh
i i i i
well i don't i don't know i don't know
yeah i don't know if um
if if that's true i think in the
beginning all all language uh changes
are are difficult you know i remember in
the um 60s hearing um
uh president johnson struggle with the
word uh negro and he would often say
[ __ ] and things like that and he by the
end of his term he was able to properly
pronounce the word negro yeah and and
that and that no and that is good you
know what i mean that meant that
uh he was raised
in a certain way and he decided to
change his language based on uh that it
was no longer appropriate to talk that
way and i think this is this problem
that mr sondheim raised uh i mean
yesterday i wrote a letter to on behalf
somebody wanted an apartment dear sirs
is what i would put for the first 60
years of my life but now i had to
struggle dear what sirs and madams
citizen ladies
well i think that's what it's about it
is about struggle it is
it is about changing patterns it is
about doing what's uncomfortable for a
while yeah because you said language is
the language of power it's power power
power words of power the deep members of
the board is clumsy yeah well i think
you might have solved that by saying
dear members of the board and you
wouldn't have to worry about it but
that's clumsy do you remember that board
well right well all right so are you
saying that
language because it's comfortable you're
gonna continue to use sexist language
because it's comfortable because it's
not clumsy because it's graceful at some
point in this transition
there has to be clumsiness there has to
be awkwardness there has to be
you know there has to be some risk and
maybe that risk is your language won't
be as beautiful and as and as uh man
woman was born free and everywhere they
are in chains
no she wasn't that okay by you
it's better it's
that's better now does it sound better
to you no
we have an example that's existed now
for 25 years which is ms miz
and i'm still getting used to it because
it still looks like they left some
letters out to me and i think it's i
think it's i agree with sapphire it's
absolutely correct that it should have
come into the language and i don't like
it okay yeah i would can i say something
yeah you can say something
we were very much involved put up mildly
in the in the miz business
uh and um i bear some of the scars
uh the
we did not use ms in print for a long
time by a deliberate decision
uh when i spoke to people i wrote to
them i say dear me call them whatever
they wanted to be called
the problem was that we the the move to
uh from ms
the reality was
was at the time before it came into
common use highly political which is not
a dirty word but is political
we felt that uh and that's also in the
answer to your question is why can't we
use obscenities let's say in a letter
the
the times depends upon its readers but
its readers cannot we feel should not
really dictate the times its own usage
the case of miz we had a problem the
problem was that a lot of people wanted
to be called different things this is no
joke we use the honorifics mister
a lot of people did not want to be
called mister we called convicts or
convicts that was my decision no matter
what they're arrested for we used to
take away the honorific for them but now
they're all honorifics because they're
called out even in court after they're
convicted i thought it was ridiculous
not to call them there are a lot of
people who don't like that there are
people didn't want to be called mister
they want criminals to be called mister
and they didn't want oh they wanted a
lot of people
did not want to be called brother or
citizen
and so when this came along we would
have made that we were making a decision
that this is no longer a political or
pressure thing but has become part of
the language so you put it in there
would have made it
no longer a political or pressure thing
but has become part of the language so
you put it in then and we did and i and
i realized later
uh nearly by looking around the faces of
the women on this time staff
and the fact that gloria steinem came to
the office bearing flowers that i had
waited too long you're waiting at least
a year for so long but we had to make
that decision for ourselves
because i grew up saying
but i i mean i think that's a real
problem the he she thing and uh but i
would be
highly irritated if i grew up and every
time when i was growing up i looked
every time somebody referred to people
of either sex it was she
uh i mean i think it's a it's an organic
problem in the language and everybody
ought to try to root it out do something
what we need is a new word which covers
both possibly i know yeah shim or
him or something
pronoun and the search for this has been
going on for a very long time anybody
got an idea for an episode
no seriously you know in the in the 19th
century there were a number of people
who tried coining them like tim and tur
were ones you know seriously proposed
for this problem you know this is not a
new problem
women use
she and men use heat i mean
women writers to say she's right that's
a courtesy
that's the courtesy how would you like
that male writers would say she
and people vice versa well that might be
[Laughter]
people willing to work i think that's
you know listen to all the fantastic
audience here this morning we're ready
to take any questions including obscene
questions yes
what happens at the times when the
reviewer goes to review a
david david
yeah
to it yes the language of [ __ ] yes
come on
florida [ __ ] how did you deal with
it
is they uh you mean the dialogue yeah
the dialogue of the day the dialogue is
i would say 60 percent uh
scatology
how do they deal with the plays without
putting the play down
uh what we normally do in most plays
not just in uh mammoths plays we don't
normally give dial
stretches of dialogue so it's really not
a problem that has ever occurred to
anybody before i heard today whether we
have to quote the obscenities in a play
another question over there
another question we don't in other
situations this young
has anybody on your panel
ever created the word
and planted it
successfully
into
the american vocabulary creating the
word i bet you have
i tried to get bill sapphire the other
sapphire
to do it and he said i would love to try
but they wouldn't print it in the time
oh well i wish to say that as the person
who my great claim to fame is i invented
bill sapphire's column one day
and i would like to say that i know bill
scified admire him enormously and he is
giving you a story
right he's giving you a story
have you done it i've had him try it
sometime but let's find that with
anybody
i want to use the noun form of the word
bodacious which did you take just go
slowly on this the noun form now
the bodacious is an adjective and i i
use the noun form that i've never seen
anybody else use which is bodacity he
had the absolute bodacity
well bodacious means sort of bold and
audacious and yeah so he's very big and
living large sort of sounds like i think
i used one today
i've never created a word but it's
always
been a fantasy of mine to take out
gullible from the dictionary
just so i can really say no gullible
isn't in isn't in the dictionary and
have people look and it's not there
[Laughter]
yeah gullible
anybody over here and it's over in the
opposition corners over there could you
take the microphone of that young fella
over there
how do you explain the acceptance of so
much yiddish expression in the american
language such as schmuck and so on yeah
hey they've accepted a lot of english
words like yes man rubbernecker gate
crasher god american words
yeah they sound great
what they mean and
uh does any of you speak yiddish
i do
i speak broken yiddish broken broken
english broken you're just broken
everything why are there so many yiddish
words because they're so expressive
well there were a lot of jews to start
with eventually
they had a lot of children and they
fanned out all over there because they
were
why is sauerkraut accepted which is not
why it's pate
yiddish words do sound i mean yeah
yeah but they sound like what they all
sound like yeah yeah
that's what you're playing small c and
so on what else can you call it
what can you call a smoke he's a smurf
that's not what it means
yes sir that's why you use it
mr we have uh rob we have uh this is uh
robert fulgum in the audience welcome
robert thank you
what accounts for the use of your note
we say you know this is and i've heard
the panel at least three people this
morning use this quite frequently um in
spoken speech it means you but not in
written speech you rarely see it but
it's very kind you know it's very common
to hear you know thrown in you know in
among very intelligent people and if you
ask them frequently they deny that they
do it that's even a more interesting
phenomenon anybody is different
verbalized like like well well uh almost
all sentences begin with well in any
exchange
and it's just it's just a sort of um
introduction
some people speak without hesitation er
h you m a lot a lot of britishers do as
a matter of fact a friend of mine the
playwright peter schaffer i've never
heard him use either well e-r-a-h-u-m
it's it's as if he edited the sentences
before they come up but they come out
spontaneously yeah you i've rarely heard
you uh bill use e-r-a-h i use it all the
time
and you know it's a form of of catching
your breath is it good
does it great on you robin yes yes it
really does so you it's your head's
shaking it's like you're stumbling and
sticking something in that's meaningless
that it has meaning you should have a
kind of device to blank it out otherwise
it drives you crazy you know
what's the assumption here when you say
you know
that you don't know
why are you talking to them unless if
they know if they don't know okay
you really should say you don't know
okay try you don't know for a change
okay
uh did i have one more over here yes i
had a lady at the back there
could you take the microphone to her
please i'm just curious how many new
words come into being annually
such as jetway
yeah i was going back to 20s when i
referred to rubbernecker
yes man pinup girl the 20s seem to
produce more words than we do today
um well actually the number of words
always goes up just because the number
of technical and scientific words uh is
always increasing
but this is something that's been
studied a lot and there are no good
answers but
the numbers people will generally throw
out are around a thousand new words a
year entering the language of which a
fairly high proportion or ones that you
wouldn't encounter because they're too
technical but a random house let's say
we add on the order of two 200 words
every year to the dictionaries now when
you see going back to that young
fellow's question where do you get them
from because etymology is really one of
your arts and some people say we
shouldn't bother with ethymology in
dictionaries anymore whether it comes
from the greek or from the latin
what do you say did you find the origins
of these new words
i mean
do you
how many
how truthful can you be to jet lag who
invented jet lag uh well jet way i think
the question she was asking is a
trademark term uh so that would go in
with a trademark label and you uh as a
matter of fact
no um
i don't know who invented jet lag and i
don't know who invented most of these
terms it's very hard because
it's usually written solid now i think
is it it's not a hyphen
it's either one or two but one or two
words no voice authorities no no
mr rosenthal is okay
but most words it's very hard to know
who coined them
it's very rare that you know this word
was coined by someone at best you can
say this was first used by someone
peanut butter
peanut girl you don't know i don't know
who called gorman mailer i think
anybody else over there yes
madam
you got a microphone
just speak loudly with you
you can i think you better
right
things on the she he
gender issue i've recently seen a lot of
people write
f
slash h e which certainly works in the
written language
okay it sounds like an author i know she
he gail sheehy excellent writer
jesse i know there's a whole new
language on computers now people using
will you be incorporating that into your
dictionary or will you be doing another
dictionary dealing with this
well we have both actually we have an
online dictionary called cyberspeak
which is really good and i recommend it
but we we've also included a very large
number of uh computer words in into the
regular dictionaries in fact more from
uh internet uh than any other area
of new words we've added in the last
number of years and most of the common
terms now all the ranging from the
regular things internet world wide web
http these initials uh to the slang like
newbie flame and spam you know these
these are all in there already
but just to go back to the gender issue
um it's
there's a tension here you know it is on
the one hand clumsy to use some of these
things and it is on the other hand
exclusive to use
male pronouns or male forms for these
things and that's just something the
language is going to have to work out i
mean there are a number of issues in
language
that have this kind of tension like i
was talking to you harry before about
the issue of spelling reform where you
have two very sensible goals one is to
make the language easier to learn and
the other is to
preserve the way the language has been
written for a long time and these are
both
you know valuable goals and
there's no easy way of saying
well we have to use he we have to use
some neutral pronoun we have to reform
the language of spelling
k-i-d-n-a-p-e-d
yeah i want two p's
yeah well kidnaped yeah sounds too close
to rape and kidnapped that's right i
always used to look at the word
m-o-l-e-s-t-e-r i think it was molster
listen folks we could go we could go on
for a long time here it's been a
fascinating morning i just want to close
with jules pfeiffer's uh
thank you again jules pfeiffer i think
summed up this morning you know in about
language he said in america there was
poor people
then they became needy
then disadvantaged then underprivileged
and he felt at the end of the day that
he still didn't have a dime but he sure
had acquired a fine vocabulary
uh and i hope you may feel that way this
morning that you've acquired a few extra
words heuristically yours goodbye and
thank you panel
thank you
you're gonna have a there's a religious
in a moment historian alan taylor talks
about william cooper's town his book
about life on the early american
frontier
one place to find book related
information on the internet is called
jane austen's corner a website devoted
to the life and work of novelist jane
austen
you can read about austin's life and
find information